salut le figaro deuxième jour de
confinement évident deuxième reportage
on va essayer de partir depuis que la
mare en direction de paris avec mon vélo
pour voir s'il ya des contrôles de
police si on a plus qu hier parce que
hier je vous rappelle dans le reportage
que j'ai publications figurent relève
mais vu à peine deux voitures de police
et du bon partout entre les vallées un
peu pour voir cette fois et on va voir
ce qui se passe aux alentours de paris
[Musique]
bon bah après dix minutes donc de trajet
on a croisé une voiture de police
quelques passants quelques voitures
c'est exactement comme il est en tout
cas je ne vois pas de différence en se
rapprochant de paris je pense que ça va
ça va être différent
maintenant sur la coulée verte un
endroit très fréquenté par les coureurs
les cyclistes les premières en général
il faut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
qui est venu profiter de
c'est beau rayon de soleil pour se
dégourdir les jambes pour sortir en
famille que pas mal de monde en tout cas
on arrive à part devant
[Musique]
alors je trouve maintenant au rif al
guerre dans le 15e arrondissement de
paris un peu plus de monde dans les rues
évidemment la distance de sécurité d'un
maître n'est pas toujours respectée j'ai
vu pas mal du groupe etc mais mais voilà
toujours tendu cas de police qui furent
pas de contrôle
[Musique]
fallu aller jusqu à montparnasse pour
fait notre premier contrôle vous pouvez
voir quatre policiers en train de
contrôler un auteur est alors une
sélection
sélectionne un petit peu au hasard
alors j'ai me rapprocher un peu et je
vais essayer de me faire contrôler tout
en filmant de manière à ce que vous
voyez comment est-ce que ça se passe je
vais essayer c'est parti
genre tu
l'attestation permet des civils
brises hockey bombe contre le très
simple
mais je demandais mon attestation j'ai
montré ma carte de presse pas de
contrôles d'identité pas de fou il n'y
rien ils avaient des masques et des
gants mais rien de particulier dans ses
contrôles en tous cas juste voilà
l'attestation et c'est tout on va
essayer d'aller maintenant sur les
champs des images assez sympa qui ont
été filmées ce matin on va les voir si
cet après midi c'est pareil si c'est
aussi des herbes deux tiennent une
police essaye de contrôler un maximum de
personnes
c'est arrivé si
vous n'avez pas besoin car de presse a
présenté une carte de france alors et
une plaisante cité je vais vous
verbaliser et puis vous ferez sauter ça
en disant que vous êtes de la presse non
monsieur c'est avec moi c'est pareil
pour tout le monde j'ai passé des
concours donc des invités vous avez
juste mettre un médecin et doit avoir sa
carte comme quoi il va bien au travail
sinon ça veut dire en gros il ya des
métiers qui font qu'on a le droit de
faire ce qu'on veut même si ces bêtes là
des stations disent qu'on peut mettre le
dessus
voilà deux stations j'ai rien qui prouve
que actuellement d'aller au travail vous
rentrez du travail je suis entré travail
ou que vous travaillez ça va des
encouragements
bon alors le premier contrôle s'était
très bien passé le deuxième un peu moins
en fait il faut avoir une attestation
sur soi en plus de la carte de presse
donc à tous les gens lisent ce qu'ils
regardent
munissez vous voilà de d'un document en
plus et alors comme l'a dit aux
policiers vous l'avez entendu c'est bête
et méchant mais voilà l'attestation même
s'il ya écrit n'importe quoi dessus vous
pouvez la prendre et couplé à la carte
de presse vous aurez aucun souci voilà
la carte de presse n'a pas suffi m'ont
mis une amende de 38 euros qui vont
m'envoyer zum envoyé avec le pouvoir
contesté dont très important
l'attestation même pour les journalistes
je vais essayer de me rapprocher au
maximum de des champs-elysées
il
[Musique]
elles figureront est arrivé à
destination finalement à parcours au
final semer d'embûches comme j'avais pu
le voir mais je pense que c'est
intéressant de montrer à peu comment
est-ce que se dérouler ces contrôles où
il était placé
j'espère que cette petite série vous
plaît si vous l'avez pas vu invite à
voir l'épisode 5 jeux sortis hier sur
les premières heures du confinement
avec la marée à châtillon et pour le
prochain épisode on essaiera de partir à
l'encontre des gens voir comment est ce
qu ils vivent cette situation historique
aujourd'hui en france et à travers le
monde
à bientôt sur figure l'est
[Musique]